et pour en parler nous sommes avec
thomas porte responsable nationale des
cheminots pcf le parti communiste
français bonjour tout-va porte merci
d'être sur notre plateau alors avant
cette grève aujourd'hui cette grande
mobilisation interprofessionnelle on a
vu que la journée d'hier a été marquée
par un séminaire gouvernemental avec
lequel l'exécutif a souhaité un petit
peu tourner la page
edouard philippe a jugé que la grève à
la sncf et à la ratp avait trop duré que
finalement elle est sans issue qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ces déclarations je
crois que c'est encore une fois jeté de
l'huile sur le feu elle est pas sans
issue
il ya une seule issue possible à la
sortie du conflit et à la sortie de la
grève c'est le retrait de la réforme
c'est le message qu'on a passé depuis le
début donc je crois que c'est en cela
elles sont pas à la hauteur de la
mobilisation qui a depuis plusieurs
semaines
on vient de le voir dans votre reportage
la mobilisation elle grandit notamment
dans d'autres secteurs dans des
professions qui étaient peu ou pas
mobilisés qui rentre dans la bataille
l'opinion publique est toujours
favorable y compris après l annonce du
retrait de l'âge pivot on avait calé
cinq points de plus qui soutenaient la
mobilisation donc je crois que le
gouvernement refuse d'entendre la colère
pourtant la mobilisation elle est ancrée
on est aujourd'hui aux 44e jour de grève
et on est prêt à tenir encore 45 46 47
50 s'il le faut jusqu'au retrait de la
réforme c'est la seule solution bon il y
encore un appel à manifester pour le 24
janvier geoffroy qui a été lancé d'ores
et déjà vous l'avais dit il ya d'autres
corps de métiers qui manifestent
aujourd'hui c'est important justement
que ces grèves ces manifestations touche
un petit peu tous les secteurs oui c'est
ce qu'on dit depuis le début je crois
que les cheminots et les agents de la
ratp ils peuvent pas gagner seuls ils
peuvent pas tenir seule une mobilisation
à bout de bras la grève par procuration
que l'inconnu en 1995 aujourd'hui elle
marche pas et c'est pour ça qu'on
lançait des appels incessants à ce que
l'ensemble des professions qu'elles
soient du public ou du privé se
mobilisent par la grève et je crois
qu'il ya deux trois ou quatre jours a
donné dans une itt salariés pour faire
plier le gouvernement sait maintenant si
tous ensemble on se met dans la luttre
qu'on peut vraiment gagner ce que les
différentes déclarations de
des ministres et notamment des doors
philippe elle montre aussi une tension
au plus haut niveau de l'exécutif qui ne
voient pas de sortie de crise qui
avaient parié sur l'essoufflement du
mouvement c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
donc on a quand même des jours de grève
qui ont suivi alors ya des hauts et des
bas mais après 45 jours de grève c'est
tout à fait normal
on a des dates à l'agenda on a
différents secteurs qui sont toujours
mobilisés et déterminés
donc je crois que voilà le gouvernement
est pareil sur ça et sur le
pourrissement
ça n'a pas été le cas non plus il n'a
pas réussi à expliquer sa réforme
aujourd'hui les français n'ont toujours
pas compris ce qu'est la mènerai de
mieux pour eux et pour raison puisqu'on
sait que ça à baisser les pensions et
enfin il avait joué la carte de
l'opinion publique il a pas réussi à la
retourner donc aujourd'hui la plus de
cartes dans les mains et la seule chose
comme nous l'a dit hier c'est qu'on a
appris qu'on allait avoir un simulateur
pour calculer notre niveau de pension
six mois après le vote de la loi
donc c'est vraiment se moquer je crois
des français qui s'est mobilisé qui ont
bien compris les dangers
donc moi je lance aujourd'hui un appel
il faut vraiment que les prochains jours
soit de très haut niveau par la grève
pour faire reculer ce gouvernement de
façon définitive
alors vous demandez toujours le retrait
total de cette réforme des retraites
mais on sait que l'âge pivot lui a été
suspendue enfin ça c'est un point sur
lequel on le voit l'ailé les
organisations syndicales
et ai été vraiment contre pourtant le
mouvement continue et ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu oui parce
que l'âge pivot en réalité c'était la
dernière carte quel gouvernement pour
essayer de faire sortir certaines
organisations syndicales de la
mobilisation mais on voit que c'est pas
aussi simple que ça puisque par exemple
pas de la cfdt qui a appelé par son
secrétaire général
arrêter de manifester mais dans certains
secteurs notamment ferroviaires par
exemple la grève continue pour la cfdt
des cheminots est d'ailleurs dans la
lettre qu'a envoyée d'or philippot au
syndicat et 10 qui retient le pivot mais
il dit qu'il n'y a pas d'accord qui
trouvait il reviendra le maître par
ordonnance est en réalité cet âge pivot
il a réglé au fond du problème de la
réforme des retraites qu'on combat c'est
à dire un système qui individualise le
droit à la retraite qui va ouvrir la
porte à leur retraite par capitalisation
et qui va populariser des millions de
salariés qui seront la retraite donc
nous on est en désaccord total avec ce
projet qui est un projet de société
donc pour nous lâche pivot n'a jamais
été j'avais dire une ligne rouge ont
demandé le retrait intégral de la
réforme est ce qu'aujourd'hui le front
syndical est toujours aussi unis il
suffit de regarder les communiqués de
presse et les appels à manifester je
crois qu'il est illettrée la
cinquantaine d organisations syndicales
zone tout j'ai envie de dire leurs
différences et leurs spécificités
mais je crois qu'on peut quand même se
félicitait après 45 jours de grève
d'avoir aujourd'hui un front syndical
qui encore aujourd'hui très large unis
qui s'entend sur un mot d'ordre simple
qui le retrait de la réforme
malgré toutes les tentatives de division
entre les salariés entre les organismes
syndicales pour tout le monde a bien
compris que l'intérêt général et d'être
ensemble et de mener une bataille
commune contre ce gouvernement
dernière question c'est que cette
manifestation interprofessionnelle
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans un programme
d'action de trois jours est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer en quoi vont
consister justement ces actions ces
prochains jours mais ce sera différent
piquet de grève différentes blocage pour
terminer sur une grande manifestation
vous l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui les
salariés des ports et docks ont annoncé
le blocage des ports vous avez montré le
port du havre mais je crois qu'elle le
port de la rochelle de marseille on a
les taux de grévistes à 100%
vous avez ce matin des blocages devant
les dépôts des ratés paie par exemple il
faut avant des actions fortes
il faut aujourd'hui monter en niveau
d'intensité sur le type d'action qui
sont menées par les salariés et on voit
que quand
des actions de haut niveau la seule
réponse qu'on nous apporte aujourd'hui
c'est la répression n'a encore eu ce
matin sur des dépôts de bus par exemple
l'emploi des crs par le gouvernement
donc je crois qu'il faut dans tous les
secteurs des mobilisations qu'elles
soient quelle qu'elle soit mais il faut
que l'intensité reste de très haut
niveau et que sur trois jours on montre
une fois de plus qu'on ne lâchera pas
face à ce gouvernement
très bien merci beaucoup en thomas pour
d'avoir répondu à nos questions j'en
perds que vous êtes responsable
nationale des cheminots ou parti
communiste français
merci